♪ ♪
>> Greg: STARBUCK ANNOUNCING A
NEW POLICY THAT LETS PEOPLE HANG
OUT AND USE THE BATHROOM WITHOUT
HAVING TO BUY ANYTHING.
THE P.R. RESPONSE TO THAT BIG
SCREWUP WHEN TWO BLACK MEN WERE
ARRESTED IN PHILLY.
STARBUCKS REALIZED THEY JUST
SENT AN OPEN INVITE TO THE
NATIONS HOMELESS.
NOW THEY SAY SLEEPING, DRUG OR
ALCOHOL USE WILL NOT BE
TOLERATED.
HOW WILL THIS WORK?
THE CONSEQUENCES WON'T BE BORNE
BY THE EXECS.
THE CEO WON'T BE ON THE
FRONTLINE.
HE WILL BE TO BUSY MONITORING
THE COMPANY'S TWITTER FEED.
INSTEAD BARISTAS WILL BE FORCED
TO ASK OTHER PATRONS OF
SOMEONE'S BEHAVIOR BOTHERS THEM.
THE WHOLE THING IS GOING TO END
UP LOOKING LIKE A RERUN FROM
COPS.
PUTS PRESSURE ON EMPLOYEES AND
THE POLICE WILL BE BLAMED BY
BOTH THE UNRULY PATRONS AND
SOCIAL JUSTICE WARRIORS NOW
PRESENT AT THESE OVERPRICED
COFFEE TEMPLES.
8,000 PLUS LOCATIONS WILL SHUT
NEXT TUESDAY FOR UNCONSCIOUS
BIAS TRAIN.
I CALL IT -- UNCONSCIOUS BIAS
TRAINING.
IF IT'S UNCONSCIOUS, HOW CAN YOU
DO KNOW YOU'RE BIASED?
YOU CAN'T KNOW YOU ARE A BIGOT.
ONLY IN TODAY'S AMERICA COULD A
COFFEESHOP DECIDE IT IS THE
MORAL CONSCIENCE OF THE NATION.
STARBUCKS, KEEP THE NEW $7
VIRTUE SIGNAL STRENGTH.
WE DRINK COFFEE TO BE AWAY, NOT
WOKE.
>> Kimberly: THAT SHOULD BE IN
YOUR NEXT BOOK.
>> Greg: JUAN, THIS PUTS THE
RESPONSIBILITY ON THE BREEZE
DOES WE JUST WANT TO SELL COFFEE
AND THEY ARE GOING TO END UP
BEING MENTAL HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS.
IN NEW YORK THERE ARE PEOPLE WHO
ARE UNSTABLE WHO COME INTO THESE
PLACES AND THEY CAN BE PRETTY
UGLY.
>> Juan: YOU ARE CRANKY TODAY
SO I AM GOING TO FORGIVE A LOT.
>> Kimberly: HE HAS GOT A SORE
THROAT.
>> Juan: WELCOME WE LOVE YOU
BUT YOU ARE CRANKY TODAY.
THIS IS A RARE MOMENT WHEN I
AGREE WITH YOU BECAUSE I'M A
REGULAR STARBUCKS CUSTOMER.
I GO IN AND I GET UPSET IF I
CAN'T USE THE BATHROOM BECAUSE
IT'S OCCUPIED OR SOMEONE IS IN
THERE FOR HOURS BUT I ALSO GET
UPSET WHEN I CAN'T FIND A PLACE
TO SIT OR STAND BECAUSE IT'S NOT
HOMELESS PEOPLE.
IT IS OFTENTIMES YOUNG PEOPLE.
THEY'VE GOT THEIR COMPUTER.
I WILL SAY -- I GET UPSET.
BUT THEN I FEEL LIKE I AM A
PRIVILEGED LITTLE'S NOT BECAUSE
MY WIFE SAID TO ME AND OTHER
PEOPLE HAVE SAID TO ME THAT
STARBUCKS INTENTIONALLY CREATED
A CULTURE WHERE THEY ARE A
COFFEE SHOP.
THEY ARE THE SO-CALLED THIRD
PLACE WHERE YOU CAN MEET
FRIENDS, HAVE DEBATES, AND THEN
YOU SAY WELL THAT GUY LOOKS KIND
OF THREATENING OR THAT GUY LOOKS
LIKE HE IS POOR CAFFEINE HERE.
THAT'S A CONTRADICTION.
AND THEN YOU DO GET INVOLVED IN,
ARE THOSE TWO GUYS ASKING TO USE
THE BATHROOM JUST BUMS OR ARE
THEY BUSINESSMEN?
>> Kimberly: TWO WORDS.
DUNKIN' DONUTS.
LET ME TELL YOU, IF THEY ARE
GOING TO ACT LIKE THIS WITH THE
NONSENSE, NO ONE IS TRYING TO
DISCRIMINATE.
ARE YOU BUYING SOMETHING IN
THERE?
DO YOU HAVE SOMETHING YOU WOULD
LIKE TO PURCHASE TO STIMULATE
THE ECONOMY OR YOU DO YOU JUST
WANT TO COME IN AND CLOGGED THE
TOILET?
I'VE HAD IT.
>> Greg: BRIAN, IMAGINE DOING
THIS AT ANY RESTAURANT.
JUST GOING TO HANG OUT.
YOU CAN'T.
YOU GO TO A GREEK DINER IN
MIDTOWN, THEY WILL THROW YOU OUT
MIDTOWN, THEY WILL THROW YOU OU
OUT.
>> Brian: THIS IS THE BEST
BLOCK AND A LONG TIME, JUAN.
I WILL SAY I KNOW FUNDAMENTALLY
I CANNOT USE SOMEBODY'S BATHROOM
OR GET CHANGED TO PAY A TOLL ON
THE SIDE BUY FROM THAT STORE.
I KNOW THAT'S IT.
>> Dana: YOUR PARENTS TAUGHT
YOU THAT.
IF >> Kimberly: ISN'T IT
COURTEOUS?
IF YOU GO INTO USE THE 7-ELEVEN
BATHROOM, BUY A SNICKERS.
>> Brian: STARBUCKS AND
DUNKIN' DONUTS HAVE SOMETHING IN
COMMON.
THEIR BATHROOMS ARE WAY TOO BIG.
YOU CAN LAND A HELICOPTER.
>> Kimberly: THERE IS GOING TO
BE A LAWSUIT.
SOMEONE IS GOING TO BE INJURED
OR STABBED AND THEN THAT'S IT.
>> Greg: BRIAN, THERE IS
SOMEBODY OVER HERE.
THIS AIN'T NO "FOX & FRIENDS" ."
DANA, THIS IS A FAILURE OF
SOCIETY TO FIGURE OUT WHAT TO DO
WITH THE HOMELESS.
>> Dana: THIS FALLS INTO MY
P.R. LAW THAT EVERY OVERREACTION
WILL CAUSE AN EQUAL OR GREATER
OVERREACTION.
THIS WAS GOING TO -- I AM FOR
BETTER AND MORE PUBLIC
RESTROOMS.
IT DOESN'T HAVE TO BE AT
SOMEBODY'S PRIVATE BUSINESS BUT
IF THIS PRIVATE BUSINESS DECIDES
IT WANTS TO DO THIS, KNOCK
YOURSELVES OUT BUT I WOULD
RATHER GO TO DUNKIN'.
>> Greg: MAYBE THEY WILL SEND
US SOME STUFF.
>> Brian: BEFORE THE SHOW IS
OVER.
A >> Kimberly: I WOULD LIKE TO